ahora vamos a aprender un poco sobre
gravedad y solo para que sepan la
gravedad es algo que sobre todo en un
curso introductorio de física o incluso
en uno de física avanzada la gravedad es
algo que podemos calcular podemos
incluso aprender a darnos cuenta de
cuáles son las las variables importantes
pero es algo que no se entiende del todo
incluso incluso aprendiendo relatividad
general podrían ustedes decir que sí que
es la deformación del espacio-tiempo y
todo eso pero es difícil tener la
intuición de por qué dos objetos solo
por tener masa están atraídos el uno al
otro
ok al menos es un poco místico para mí
pero en este vídeo vamos a aprender
sobre la ley de la gravitación de newton
que es bastante útil para para muchos
muchos casos ok entonces la ley de la
gravitación de newton nos dice que la
fuerza de atracción entre dos objetos es
igual a la constante de la gravitación
universal que es g y que de hecho no lo
investigue para ustedes si lo tengo aquí
abajo en verde que multiplica
el producto de las masas de los dos
objetos de los que estemos hablando y
dividimos entre la distancia al cuadrado
y la distancia por supuesto entre los
dos objetos de los que estemos hablando
entonces vamos a utilizar esta fórmula
para calcular por ejemplo la fuerza de
gravitación que que se ejerce sobre por
ejemplo sobre mí si esto si estamos en
la tierra aunque entonces pueden ustedes
pensar
que esta es la tierra
la tierra y está más o menos ok
ahí está más o menos y digamos que yo
estoy parado sobre la tierra o pueden
ser ustedes quien sea
ok entonces vamos a tratar de calcular
cuál es la fuerza de atracción que hay
entre mí o entre este personaje que
pueden ser ustedes y la tierra ok
entonces vamos a necesitar la masa de la
tierra que también ya la busqué por
ustedes en wikipedia y es de 5.97 por 10
a la 24 kilogramos la constante de la
gravitación universal que de hecho no
estoy del todo seguro si realmente es
una constante es decir si si a lo mejor
aplica a todas las escalas posibles pero
al menos para los fines que vamos a
estar trabajando si es útil es 6.67 por
10 a la menos 11 si se dan cuenta este
es un número sumamente pequeño verdad y
las unidades son metros cúbicos /
kilogramo por segundo al cuadrado
ustedes dirán hoy estas unidades son un
poco extrañas y tienen razón son son
bastante raras pero funcionan muy bien
para qué
aplicar aquí todas las unidades nos
quedan justamente en newtons que 'con
kilogramos metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado si te das cuenta
aquí tenemos metros cúbicos kilogramos
segundo al cuadrado si multiplicamos dos
veces por kilogramos se cancela a uno y
te queda solo kilogramos y luego si
dividimos entre distancia al cuadrado
eso sería [ __ ] algo así como en metros
cuadrados que se cancelan con dos de
estos metros cúbicos y nos quedan metro
kilogramos sobre segundo al cuadrado así
que queda bastante bien aunque ya
entonces necesitamos calcular cuál es la
distancia de la tierra al objeto que en
este caso sería yo y cuando estamos
diciendo la distancia y eso es algo que
hay que tener muy en cuenta cuando
trabajemos atracción entre cuerpos
debido a la gravedad es que esa
distancia se calcula del como la
distancia entre los centros de masa
entre los dos objetos
pintar bien esta línea
entonces necesitamos calcular esta
distancia del centro de masa de la
tierra que es justamente el centro de la
tierra hasta el centro de masa de este
personaje de mí digamos que que está más
o menos que no sé cómo por mi ombligo
pero bueno no sé mi ombligo estará a un
metro de altura qué sé yo no sé ok
entonces nos dicen que la al menos la
distancia del centro de la tierra a la
superficie es de seis mil 371 kilómetros
eso es lo mismo que seis millones 371
mil metros o en notación científica son
6.371
71 por 10 a las 6 metros muy bien
entonces esto es escribiéndolo en
notación científica y ya tenemos todo
para calcular cuál es la fuerza de
atracción entre digamos entre ustedes o
entre mí y la tierra muy bien entonces
esta fuerza será igual a la constante g
de 6.67 por 10 a la menos 11 ahorita
vamos a omitir las unidades ok que
multiplica a la masa de mi masa digamos
bueno no estoy seguro de si quiero dar a
conocer mi masa en este vídeo pero
digamos puede ser la masa de cualquier
persona aunque hoy vamos a ponerlo como
m minúscula
ok que multiplica a la masa de la tierra
que multiplica
a ponerlo todo en paréntesis a 5.97 por
10 a la 24 y dividimos entre la
distancia al cuadrado entonces serían
seis puntos de 371 por diez a las seis
metros seis mil 371 kilómetros o seis
millones 371 mil metros más un metro
digamos de donde se encuentra mi centro
de masa vamos a omitir ese metro es muy
poquito para comparado con la el radio
de la tierra así que vamos a suponer que
mi centro de masa está justo en la
superficie de la tierra así que
tendríamos que dividir entre 6.371 por
diez a las seis y todo esto elevado al
cuadrado muy bien entonces vamos a ir
haciendo todas estas operaciones la
fuerza será igual podemos sacar esta m
hasta acá afuera
y vamos hasta aquí y vamos a multiplicar
vamos a multiplicar 6.67 por 5.97 6.67
por 5.97 y eso nos da 39.82 digamos esto
es 39.82 y luego multiplicamos las
potencias de 10 que es 10 a la 24 por 10
a la menos 11 las las reglas de los
exponentes nos dicen que se suman los
exponentes es decir 24 menos 11 nos
queda 10 a la 13 verdad y luego
dividimos entre
6.371 y lo elevamos al cuadrado nos da
40 puntos 58 vamos a ponerlo como 40
puntos 59 40 punto 59 por 10 a la 6
elevado al cuadrado 10 a la 6 al
cuadrado es lo mismo que 10 a la 12
verdad entonces ahora lo único que nos
queda es dividir estos números y restar
los exponentes de las potencias de 10
verdad entonces esto será igual a la
masa a la masa que multiplica a quien
multiplica
39.82 entre 40 y 59 que es 9.1 perdón
0.900 81 vamos a ponerlo así como vamos
a ponerlo como 0 punto vamos a ponerlo
con verde
0.900 81 por 10 ala por 10 a la 13
12 es 1 por 10 verdad entonces lo que
obtuvimos es que la fuerza de atracción
es igual a 9.81 verdad si multiplicamos
por 10 este número nos dan 9.81 por la
masa aunque por mi masa o la masa de
cualquier objeto que estemos hablando
pero lo que hay que tomar en cuenta es
que esto es lo mismo por la segunda ley
de newton que la aceleración debido a la
gravedad por la masa verdad por la masa
eso quiere decir que podemos cancelar
las masas y nos queda que la aceleración
debido a la gravedad es justamente de
9.81 y si hiciéramos bien el trabajo de
las unidades y demás nos quedarían
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
entonces aquí hemos demostrado cuán sólo
utilizando lo digamos estos números cuál
es el valor de la aceleración
la gravedad
en la superficie terrestre ahora en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a ver qué pasaría
con la fuerza de gravedad si
estuviéramos por ejemplo en un planeta
con la mitad del radio de lo que tiene
la tierra y la mitad de su masa así que
nos vemos pronto